alfredo quiere llenar un globo esférico
con tanta agua como sea posible los
globos que compró se estiran hasta
alcanzar un radio de 3 pulgadas si el
volumen de una esfera es de deere una
función con respecto del radio igual a
cuatro tercios de pi por radio al cubo
cuál es el volumen de agua en pulgadas
cúbicas que alfredo puede verter en un
globo
aquí nos dan la función para calcular el
volumen y si tenemos el radio en
pulgadas pues el volumen también está en
pulgadas cúbicas nuestra función es de
deere con respecto al radio igual a
cuatro tercios de pi por radio al cubo y
nos dicen que los globos se estiran
hasta alcanzar un radio de tres pulgadas
la entrada serán tres pulgadas de radio
y la usaremos en nuestra función donde
veamos una r vamos a sustituir tres
nuestra función del volumen
con una entrada 3 va a ser igual a 4
entre 3 de pi
y esta idea los sustituimos por 3 3 al
cubo
esto a su vez es igual 3 al cubo es 27 4
entre 3 por pi
por 27 pero 27 entre 39 esto se cambió
por un
99 por 4 36 esto va a ser igual a 36 pi
en pulgadas cúbicas
pulgadas
al cubo
y ese es el resultado de nuestra función